تاثيرات الحرب روسيا الاوكرانيه تجاوزت
الحدود الجغرافيه ووصلت الى بلدان بعيده
جدا عن منطقه الصراع الحديث هنا عن دول
اسيا تحديدا الفقيره منها فما هي علاقه
حرب اوكرانيا باسيا
[موسيقى]
دول كالهند والصين تحولت في السنوات
الاخيره للاعتماد على مصادر الوقود
المتجدد كالغاز المسال الا ان الحرب دفعت
بدول اوروبا لمقاطعه الغاز الروسي
واستيراده من دول اخرى ما ادى لزياده
الطلب ورفع سعر الغاز الطبيعي لنحو عشره
اضعاف دول اسيا الغنيه مثل اليابان قامت
بشراء الغاز الطبيعي بسعره الباهب لكن
دولا كالصين والهند خفضت وارداتها من
الغاز الى الخمس ولجات لتوليد الطاقه
اللازمه عن طريق الفحم الامر الذي يرفع من
زياده انبعاثات الكربون ويزيد درجه حراره
الكوكب بنهايه المطر
[موسيقى]